الآن إذا نظرت إلى مجموعة المشاكل
التي واجهتها الصناعة إلى جانب المشكلة
الوجودية بالطبع أه
منذ حوالي عامين الآن هناك حرب في أوكرانيا
هناك ارتفاع في أسعار الوقود هناك
نقص في الموظفين يسبب الكثير من
التأخير ثم هناك وقود للطائرات
نفسها التي ارتفعت بنسبة 80 90 في
المائة ، فإن أسعار الطائرات تتفوق
على أسعار النفط الخام ، ومن الواضح أن أحد أكبر
التكاليف لشركات الطيران
هو الوقود ، وقد ارتفع بنسبة 50 في المائة
منذ الطائرات منذ فبراير ، وهو ضعف
ارتفاع أسعاره في عام 2019.
بالنسبة إلى منشورات المستهلكين ،
ارتفع متوسط ​​سعر التذكرة في
الولايات المتحدة الآن 66
من أكتوبر في اللوحات هنا في إياتا.
تحدثت إلى الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعة
الخطوط الجوية القطرية وعذراء فيرجن
وأستراليا ،
دعنا
نراكم سنقترب جدًا من 40
في المائة من هيكل التكلفة لدينا الذي
سيكون من الوقود فقط
لحسن الحظ ، لقد تم التحوط
لنا في السنة المالية الماضية ، وقد تم التحوط مرة أخرى
إلى نسبة أقل في
هذه السنة المالية.
ع ولكن لن يساعد ذلك كثيرًا
في نهاية اليوم ، فسيتعين علينا
رفع الأسعار لتغطية التكلفة المتزايدة
للوقود ، فكرة أن تكلفتك يمكن أن تتضخم
بنسبة 50 إلى 75
في المائة في واحدة من أكبر رافعات التكلفة لديك و
لا يمكنك رفع السعر ، لا يمكنك استرداده
، أعني أنه لا يعمل فقط
ولدينا التزام كصناعة لضمان
سفر العالم مرة أخرى ،
واستعادة الاتصال العالمي مرة أخرى ولكن يتعين علينا
القيام بذلك  بطريقة مستدامة
ولدينا عامين حيث تعرض معظمنا
لخسائر فادحة
جدًا لذا لا أعتقد أن هناك أي خيار
سوى ارتفاع السعر
وبقاء ضوابط السعة
لضمان أن ذلك ممكن